[soft music]
[faint grunting]
[lion growls]
NARRATOR: Tata is ready.
Lured by the promise of water,
the heavyweights arrive.
[grunting]
Enormous beasts with enormous
thirst and enormous horns.
[lion growls]
Tata can't take them on alone.
She won't have to.
The teams are primed and ready.
[music intensifies]
Time to see what
the boys can do.
[buffalo lowing]
Under Tata's guidance,
the teams isolate a pair
of buffalo, female and calf.
Perfect.
[music intensifies]
The teacher creates
a distraction--
[buffalo lowing]
--while her students go in
for the mother of all prizes.
A banquet for a hungry pride.
[lion growls]
The teams finally
show their true worth.